baby backs pochi
my powers will become yours for you
[Music]
hi everyone is Charlie this is gonna be
my non-spoilery Shazam review I'll talk
a little bit about what I liked about
the movie what I felt like didn't work
and where it fits into the pantheon of
modern DC films there is an IMAX ticket
giveaway - all you need to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Shazam on the video so here we go
movie itself is a little bit like
Christopher Reeve Superman classic
Superman mixed with Tom Hanks big they
even said as much when they first
started shooting they were started to
post behind-the-scenes videos and they
literally mentioned Superman and Tom
Hanks big but it's also a little bit
Goonies with a little bit of stranger
things energy but with magic if you've
been a comic book reader or you've read
some version of him when he used to be
Captain Marvel in the classic Shazam
comics they've sort of rebooted that
during the rebirth era and they are sort
of leaning on the stranger things of it
all with the Shazam family but it does
lean hard on the Shazam family so if
you're big fan of that genre of films I
felt like they did a good job with this
we got to talk about Zachary Levi though
everybody had so many questions when he
was first cast he doesn't look huge but
I feel like he was born to play this
character he's got this level of
childlike innocence in his adult body
that is the Shazam character from the
comics if you've ever seen any of his
episodes of Chuck it's a little bit like
that a little bit of a manchild but in a
light playful way and he could not be
more jazzed up to be a superhero which
is basically what happens to him during
the Chuck series so I feel like lately
DC movies have been a breath of fresh
air where you have people like Aquaman's
character and now Shazam's character
that are generally jazzed up and exude
this positive vibe about trying to be
the most that they could possibly be in
the case of Aquaman obviously he's the
king of Atlantis Shazam is kind of like
the king of magic on earth technically
he's sort of the guardian of the rock of
eternity and the seven deadly sins just
like he is in the comics but the movie
itself does a good job of explaining the
mythology without getting too bogged
down in it in the film does a great job
of referencing things from all over the
different errors of the Shazam comics
from the classic stuff from the new 52
the more recent rebirth stuff when it
comes to the story they were really
upfront about what they were doing what
they were not doing so I mean I don't
feel like it's a spoiler to say that
black Adam is not a big character during
the Shazam movie even though the rock
was cast as Black Adam a couple years
ago there's a certain totalmix that
there going forward that he just doesn't
jive
and I don't think they're ready for that
character so when we get to my spoiler
review and we start talking about Easter
eggs I'll talk about more black Adam
stuff and where the future this
character is there are so many
references to the other DC movies that
is gonna take me a couple more times of
watching this to catch all the Easter
eggs so if you really are big fans of
Easter egg hunts this movie will keep
you busy for a little while but I
actually think that the movie gets much
better in the second half when they move
past the Batman Superman Justice League
references of it all and it just focuses
on doing its own thing for all of its
cheesiness and self-aware jokes there
are genuinely some hardcore action
scenes but nothing that will traumatize
children that you may take to this if
you have younger tweens or any that
you've taken to other superhero DC or
marvel movies they'll probably be fine
but given all the criticisms that people
have levied against the marketing and
the trailers it'll be really funny to
talk about the WTF moments when we get
to spoiler videos in the next couple of
weeks
Dillon greasier who played Freddie
Freeman he was a great sidekick to young
Billy when it was the azure angel
version of the character an adult Billy
when it was Zachary Levi walking around
in the costume I definitely prefer the
scenes where it's Zachary Levi Shazam
walking around with him they had a
really good chemistry together I wasn't
a big fan of asher angels before i don't
watch a lot of disney channel
programming and that's kind of the area
he comes from so if you have young kids
in your family and you're taking them to
see this movie they might recognize him
more than they recognize Zachary Levi
his performance was pretty authentic to
Geoff Johns new 52 Billy Batson and the
writing was generally faithful there
were a couple of big changes they had to
make because of things that they didn't
include from that storyline but I'll
talk about that when I get to my spoiler
video the director David Sandberg did a
great job he's been talking a lot about
how he came on to the project most of
the time you'd be surprised that small
indie directors come on to do these but
it's been happening more and more lately
with big Marvel and big DC films David
Sandberg is mostly known for doing small
horror films like James Wan which is a
nice coincidence because he just did
Aquaman but the reason why the studio's
like these types of people so much is
because they're much better at working
with actors than typical big-budget
tentpole directors they have some great
action scenes it's genuinely exciting
seeing magic on-screen in the DC
Universe for the first time there are so
many great magic characters that I hope
that they get to eventually the movie
itself is set during the Christmas
holiday so if you're big fan of
action movies or any movies at all set
during the Christmas period it just
provides for a lot of really interesting
story scenarios and visual elements in
the film Christmas tends to be a much
more colorful time of year because of
all the lights the Christmas trees it
lends itself a lot better to the tone
and the story that the film is going
with you know a little bit lighter
Christopher Reeves Superman mixed with
Tom Hanks Biggs so the story is sort of
like this childhood coming-of-age story
in a world where the Justice League
exists about the families that you make
for yourself not necessarily the ones
that you're born with about overcoming
childhood trauma the villain Mark Strong
you'll recognize from Green Lantern in a
billion other things he does a really
good job of playing big movie villains
but if you're still bummed out about the
way Green Lantern turned out that was so
long ago but people are still kind of
salty about it this film does make good
use of him and it is very aware of the
way that it uses him so when the way the
Green Lantern got a little bit hammy
with the way it treated his characters
Shazam is very aware of what it's doing
at all times there was that recent
trailer where they had like the funny
parody fight mid-air that I posted a
video for wait what you will beg for
mercy are you making some like biggie
evil guys speech right now or something
you're like a mile away from me while I
see his mouth moving as I feast on your
heart you have mark Strong's dr. sivana
mid-air evil guys speechifying to Billy
who's so far away that he can't hear a
word that he's saying and he just stops
him okay fine you know like I can't hear
you so we're gonna stop this did you
start punching each other again I
wouldn't say that it revolutionizes the
superhero genre but it does a lot of the
same things the Deadpool did to his
credit though Deadpool has also since
then taken a lot of shots at the DC
movies the music was great the original
score was great something that you don't
think about often too is that eventually
all these heroes will team up in another
Justice League film and they'll each
have their own theme songs those theme
songs will have to blend well together
it's a couple really cool twist in the
story we'll have to wait till spoilers
to talk about there are two post credits
scenes there's a mid-credits scene in an
actual genuine post-credit scene so do
stay through the entire credits the film
genuine
where's this heart on its sleeve but
there are a couple moments that are a
little too over-the-top like over over
the top but the movie itself is meant to
be very self-aware so I feel like if you
go into the movie understanding that
then a lot of the jokes will work a lot
better for you my new ranking of the DC
movies from least favorite to favorite
some of these are grouped together
because I like them about the same in
terms of quality the bottom of the
barrel is Suicide Squad no surprise
there I feel like that's at the bottom
of almost everybody's list then Justice
League then Batman V Superman just
because I feel like that film was less
changed by the studio Justice League was
a bit of a Franken mess where you have
one directors vision then you get Joss
Whedon coming in at the eleventh hour
and trying to change what the original
vision was going to be with not enough
time so it just winds up being released
in a very incomplete way you get the
mustache gate of it all so that's why
Batman V Superman is higher than Justice
League on my list because regardless of
how you feel about the movie it is
genuinely one directors vision for an
actual story Thin Man of Steel which was
obviously also complete vision from a
single director with a little bit of
help from Christopher Nolan the tone was
a little too dour for a modern version
of Superman for my liking but hopefully
Henry Cavill will get a chance to make
that Man of Steel sequel so they'll get
a really solid Superman film out before
he decides to leave the character or
before another big Justice League
team-up then above that it's actually a
pretty solid three-way tie between
Aquaman Wonder Woman and Shazam because
they all have their strengths and their
weaknesses there are a couple things
about each of those movies that I feel
like just doesn't work but for the most
part it feels like the universe is going
in a really positive direction so if
you've been really hoping for a solid DC
movie universe it looks like they're
pretty much there like Shazam is
probably gonna be another big hit for
them it's a little too early to do box
office predictions but I'll say I'm
expecting it to do near Wonder Woman
numbers which is great because I think
they spent a little bit less money on it
so it doesn't have to earn quite as much
money to make it into profit and earn a
greenlight for a sequel but the director
did say that they were actually talking
about doing a sequel and he would come
back for that so regardless of what kind
of Black Adam crossover movies they do
in the future there will be Shazam
sequels Zachary Levi also said that he
really wants to be in Justice League but
it's probably to be a couple years
before they make another Justice League
film so we don't need to worry too much
about that right now overall really
solid hit they deserve a round of
applause what you do have a chance to
see the movie let me know what you think
of it in the comment
below my spoiler full review will post
sometime either next week when we get a
little bit closer to the movie then I'll
do post credits scenes I'll do Easter
eggs all those videos just leave your
requests in the comments below if you
have big questions they'll be more DC
posting suit I'll name a giveaway winner
when I post that while you wait for
everything click here for all my Shazam
trailer videos and click here to learn
who the most powerful Avenger is heading
into Avengers endgame in Marvel phase 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]